compagnie de bernard chercher offert un
joli avec
[Musique]
bien sûr avec le
nombre allemand vous l'avez là
cette percée les prix de l'endurance
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
à
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faire monter les escaliers
[Musique]
des poulets espérer souffler sur des
moineaux
[Musique]
m
l'avant
[Musique]
respirer
[Applaudissements]
vous n'êtes pas une question indiscrète
bernard tapie d'avoir tapé un nom bien
célèbre un homme d'affaires connu par
monts et par vaux qui dirige d'état
d'état d'état d'état société avec une
pêche est une forme incroyable alors
comment faites-vous
partie sportive depuis je suis grand
comme ça ça m'a peut-être d'ailleurs
donné un état d'esprit qui diffère un
peu de certains de mes confrères et des
vôtres
parce que dans le sport on apprend on
apprend d'abord le fair play on apprend
ce très important on apprend à apprécier
à sa juste valeur le succès de ses
voisins car même lorsqu'on est deuxième
on applaudit pour le premier c'est pas
le cas dans votre métier c'est pas non
plus
deuxièmement on apprend aussi que l'état
d'âme le mental l'intelligence tout ça
on peut pas le l'extraire de son corps
en fait il est le reflet de l'état de
santé de son corps et c'est vrai qu'on
est triste quand on est malade c'est
vrai qu'on est comme vous gay quand on
est en forme et donc je crois que il est
indispensable d'être physiquement bien
en forme si on veut être mentalement
bien disposés si vous faites dire non
comscore
je fais deux types de sports je fais des
sports de fond ou le vélo puis je fais
des sports un peu violent et un peu à
peu toniques et là vous nous suiviez
bien quand j'étais surpris je fais tu
peux faire plusieurs heures comme ça ça
c'est extraordinaire ces photos si vous
avez des régimes bages et obligatoires
du mat nacion je veux pas ça
je fume pas ne boit pas et c'est vrai
que c'est une une société qui s'occupe
du bien manger c'est un paradoxe en fait
c'est que on n'a jamais mangé autant et
on n'a jamais souffert de tant de
manques on ne manque de vitamines on
vende au dos ligot les mots en manque de
fer de magnésium de toute chose pour
vous alors je crois qu'il faudrait
apprendre à bien manger pas forcément
quantitativement et qualitativement
réponse à ya quarante ans que des gens
militent dans ce sens là et c'est dès
d'apprendre aux gens leur expliquant qu'
il faut bien manger pour être bien dans
sa peau alors beaucoup de bicyclettes et
moi d'autres je fais la préparation en
full contact qui est un sport tonique
qui permet de faire partir la pression
ça et les trois quarts du temps on est
un peu bloquée on s'autocensure et on
n'ose pas faire exploser et or je crois
plutôt que de prendre une colère sur sa
secrétaire il vaut mieux taper sur
quelque chose et hurler sa rage où on en
a besoin et la préparation au full
contact est une préparation comme tous
les sports de combat où on apprend à en
même temps qu on donne un coup on se
libère d'une énergie qui est interne ça
évite d'avoir des scènes de ménages est
d'avoir des collaborateurs qui souffle à
ses parents s'en prévaut réunion je fais
ça la nuit
et le vélo levine au vélo c'est un sport
de fond qui permet de garder le souffle
de pouvoir faire un peu de jogging comme
ça tout en ayant une capacité
respiratoire
intéressante et puis je crois surtout
que c'est un moment donné on a on a
forcément besoin de ressembler un peu à
ce que l'on à ce que l'on est et je
crois que je défends à la fois par
bernard hinault à la fois par la vie
claire à la fois par look à la fois par
adams certaine idée d'un nouveau
management comme vous l'avez fait vous
dans votre métier je veux dire que avant
que vous existiez y avait des cours de
gymnastique 1 et vous avait fait
découvrir par à la fois l'image que vous
projetez la façon dont vous abordez le
problème vous avez fait voir qu'on
pouvait faire cette gymnastique est
emmerdant trop bien le dire vous pouvez
la faire en riant pour référence amusant
et donc on en sait trop tardé à profiter
pleinement
on écoute reprise non c'est pas ça et
moi c'est pareil si je veux donner aux
gens l'envié d'adhérer à ce que je sens
que je réclamais ce que je représente il
faut que je donne l'exemple moi même
donc je fume pas je ne bois pas je suis
heureux de faire les choses comme vous
voulez faites
janvier en formule 1 est un gamin staff
type formidable est-ce que vous suivez
ça vient ma première question tout à
l'heure un régime alimentaire non pas du
tout mais attention je fais attention je
fais pas n'importe quoi j'ai souvenir un
jour vous êtes vous avoir entendu dire
vous voulez une crotte en chocolat et
comme on sait que malade des chocolats
je les ai pas vraiment vous m'avez dit
mais si elles sortent de la vie claire
ya absolument tout ce qu'il faut dedans
pour ne pas grossir mais non parce
qu'objectivement quand on a quand on a
la chance d'avoir des pannes à voile a
la chance d'avoir votre âge en effet
pour pouvoir manger ni trop de chocolat
oui c'était par conséquent si on la
mange pas sur la manche lassée quelque
part il ya quelque chose qui va pas bien
aurélien alors le vrai problème c est ce
qu on s'attaque en refusant certain
plaisir d'une façon efficace aux
problèmes ou est-ce qu'on se donne les
moyens de pouvoir faire des petites
bêtises comme ça moi je crois plutôt
quand on vous voit tous les deux c'est
exactement ça en tout cas ça fait très
très gentil des zones u participer avec
nous un énorme bravo parce que c'est
c'est eh oui mais moi je suis très
content d'autant que d'après ce que je
sais à la fin une douche
[Rires]
la douche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]